[Music]
hello Janice coughs OH
before I begin uh I just want to thank
all of you for giving me this
opportunity around ten years ago I left
my hometown in the heart of the
northwest of Argentina and I literally
could not have envisioned that I'll be
here speaking today to all of you so
thank you earlier today earlier this
week actually I was asking all the
speakers in line if they had any rituals
that they took before going on stage
this is the largest audience I've been
in front of and Lori vos suggests that I
take a selfie to help me with my stage
fright so that's okay with you could we
take one at least yeah all right let's
do that thank you so much so we go there
can we say actors will see why later one
two three actors nobody okay well it was
worth a shot
so all right for those of you don't know
me my name is Leandro and I work as a
research engineer at source the
Stockholm Research Center we're a fully
open source nonprofit dedicated to
advanced humanity and our interactions
with computers today I'm here to talk
about us all of us and about our history
building software for human beings
hopefully by the end of this talk I
would have done two things the first one
is I would have shown you that while the
web today flourishes with incredible
ideas we have a great many lessons to
learn from your past and the second one
is perhaps I will have compelled some of
you to challenge the ways that we build
web applications both at a technical
level but also philosophically so let us
begin and in this period of fun let's
play a small game right I will describe
a program and some of the features it
has and you'll try to guess our loudest
name are you offer it yeah cool I know
we're all tired is class day but please
bear with me can you think of a program
that lets you draw maybe free handedly
right and then you can resize your
shapes at will
does this program lets you set
constraints for those shapes and say
that they will be centered or maybe
parallel to something else or evenly
spaced can you make copies of those
shapes and if you make a copy and update
the regional does the copy update as
well anybody any guesses Photoshop
anyone else alright I was hoping someone
would actually say sketch these are some
of the features that you can see in
sketch but in reality I was referring to
sketch pad sketch pad is a program
developed by dr. Ivan Sutherland back in
1963 and yet this is this old this is
really over 50 years old so I want to
show you a little bit of what sketch pad
looks like let's play that we can see
that he just start sketching something
on screen right it looks like a rivet or
maybe some sort of like square with a
base he has a cross border and if you
see in the center of the cross bar now
to draw an arc right then he's gonna
point to the different edges of the
product the the drawing and it's gonna
ask the program to make all of them
mutually perpendicular turns on the
constraint solver and as the program
solves the constraints it forces the
crossword to change which forces the act
to change yielding is perfectly
symmetrical rivets this is really old
stuff then he shows that no matter how
you distort it it comes up with a
symmetrical solution which is pretty
cool this constraints could have be more
complicated right
could have been ratios between lines and
you know or two other drawings let's see
one last example there turns it on there
you go perfectly symmetrical rivet
another important idea that we'll see
here and it's practically the first time
this was shown is the idea of a master
and an instance right he was working
before in this master drawing and now he
has an instance of it on screen that is
completely independent from from master
you can see this rotating it is trying
to fit it into the plank it's a it's a
tedious process it takes a little bit of
time the display flickers because it's
not actually a display it's an
oscilloscope
they do not have this place back then
and perfect there you go
it took me a long time to time that but
we can relate nowadays to repot this
pattern using different names perhaps we
think of components and elements in
react or classes and objects in
JavaScript he creates a few more
instances then he goes back to the
master you can see that he'll just
remove some of the crossbar lines and
when he goes back you know lo and behold
the the copies the instances the
elements have been updated yeah this is
a this is the work of Ivan Sutherland
who in 1963 published his seminal work
on coal sketchpad the thesis is online
you can read it is pretty intense
Ivan Sutherland this development during
the thesis write all by himself and when
Alan Kay one of his students asked he
asked him how did he manage to create
this first object orientated system and
the first graphical interface system all
within one year by himself
the guy just reply well he didn't know
it was hard which is a interesting
either way I was really said the davar
high for three people that came after
him right he set a direction for the
likes of Douglas Engelbart for example
the fellow who created the first
computer mouse an ankle burning his team
at the Stanford Research Institute they
developed during the span of around ten
years a system that is kind of
incredible I can't quite grasp that it
has existed the system was called the
online system for historical reasons
that I'm not gonna get into and it was
first team up publicly in 1968 so what
I'm gonna show you right now dates long
time ago as well this has been dubbed
the mother of all demos
let's look at why and this is audio so
hopefully you will be not the last play
we have I'd like to see you while I'm
working on it
so oops available through the kind of
display we have I'd like to see you
while I'm working on it so before I can
do that I have to set up my display in a
certain way we can here here do glass
doing the lights order I see it over
like that that leaves a corner up there
and I say he's now easily automatic
switch entering in the camera picture
from the camera mounted on his console
such as a camera mounted I'm from a
different country right now California
audio you can see my work you can point
out it and I can see your face and we
can talk so let's do some collaborate
this video comes tiling 9l68 what do
want me to think pika
there's nobody here but a large audience
go alright alright so let's uh let's go
talk about information retrieval and a
lot of things I've been showing them and
jumping around and finding your way
lower delay demon is a portrayal I gave
about MLS as an instrument on complex
data structures it shows them how we can
get around and find things I showed them
the content analyzers they're discussing
some matters of the presentation they
were damned there and then they
proceeded to link workspaces to the
point that they're essentially doing
live coding if you look carefully in a
second from now you're gonna see two
Mouse's on the same computer they're
actually modifying the same the same
environment this is live coding I mean
seriously this presentation is epical if
you haven't watched it after this talk
or whenever you're home just look for it
look it up on YouTube the mother of all
demos there you go you see two Mouse's
there it's kind of in the same oh yes we
discussed a contextual background we can
move on to the last piece of history
that we need for this presentation and
that is Sarah Oaks Park the Palo Alto
Research Center in this branch of
Serac's we found the likes of Alan Kay
Adelle Goldberg and Dan Ingalls who
created small talk small talk is a
language that was designed to be a
vehicle for human-computer symbiosis and
I'm not talking about symbiosis like the
Borg in Star Trek it's a language that
is designed to fail
background fast and let you express
yourself sort of like a musical
instrument would it offers two
programmers two core capabilities
the first one is classes and objects
which are used to represent things right
and processes and the second one is
message passing that provides the
communication layer right a way for
these objects to talk to each other
something we're noting is that Alan Kay
has repeatedly said that when he he
invented object-oriented programming the
important part was not the objects
themselves but the messages it was a
communication what he really cared about
let's look at an example of this system
we can see here an animation of a ball
and what appears to be some sort of a
static website right but in reality the
animation is being programmed as objects
so we can stop it and step through it so
you can see here it's gonna go through
until it finds the right frame hidden
opens up a browser and this browser lets
you see the messages that this object in
particular can receive right that you
can send to it after finding the right
message he's kind of going to the the
painter tool will do the same thing and
find that okay we have the current frame
message on the top and we need to find a
message to link the current frame into
the painting tool so it's gonna look for
the picture arrow is gonna then sort of
sketch in our row and the system will
recognize that you have two messages
selected you want to send a message from
between objects so you can type in there
what is that you want to say so he's
telling hey painter here's the message
picture give me the picture that you're
currently using
I'll link you to the bouncing which is
the name of the object that represents
the animation current frame so the
current frame of the animation above and
after he sends the message but we get
the frame below this isn't completely
live this is not something that has been
prepared beforehand it's the live system
that the user is actually going to use
right all of these simply built yeah
sorry all of these applications right
are customisable by the users to feed
their needs they really turn the whole
computer into some sort of bicycles for
the mind and all of these examples have
been built on each other to formalize
the idea that our world
concurrent everything around us is
happening in parallel from us and we
communicate with everything around us by
sending this message it's just like
right now I'm not letting you access the
memory in my head I'm sending messages
to you so we communicate yeah the
underlying philosophical grounds that
all of these people shared the vision
they had was to advance the human
intellect we're not talking about
for-profit companies trying to lure you
into buying a product but about
altruistic men and women dedicating
their lives to forward all of us so
we've seen the sketchpad
the NL s and small talk now what are
some of the learnings we can take from
them and apply today I want to talk
about two things two ideas the first one
is the competition model behind these
applications how is it that Iran and the
second one is the philosophy behind them
so let's begin with the first one when
we model application is small talk we
model it in terms of objects that
interact with each other VM message
passing each one of these objects
performs hopefully one very small task
and that's the number of messages right
that it understands and that it sends to
other objects it may have some internal
state that can change over time normally
one of these small talk applications
right can have millions or hundreds of
millions of objects and you may even
think of those tiny objects as tiny
computers on their own it's kind of like
an internet inside of your application
if you look at this diagram we can see
that we have some button that's sending
essentially an input object a message
called clear so it clears itself and a
container object is sending a draw
message to tell input where it has to be
drawn the same happens with a slider
that is linked to a graph so you can
update the graph through the slider and
the synchronizer might send new values
into the graph that will in turn update
a slider the underlying principles
behind how small talk works right have
been formalized with some differences as
the actor model in the actor model we
have separate actors essentially
independent entities right that they're
executed completely independently
in isolation they saw problems by
collaboration and they collaborate with
each other by message passing they
collaborate by talking to each other
just like humans do modeling the system
with this approach has three interesting
properties the first one is failure
isolation by default the second one is
in a synchronous nature and the third
one is that it's really parallelizable
let's talk a little bit about the first
one then we're gonna go to the second on
the third show of hands have you ever
seen an application a website that was
completely unusable because of some
unhandled exception that blew up the
complete application stack yes or no
pretty much every form the audience is
like yeah that's that's the way it goes
I think we all have right if our
applications are normally composed of
dozens of this independently of
collaborating systems why do we treat
them as a single monolith that has to be
very very carefully programmed I don't
quite understand that we know there are
applications are scaling massively in
complexity right and prescribing these
user experiences for people that use
them is perhaps a definition of a day
job for some of us so why are we risking
so much in the action model an actor
failing does not take down the entire
system in fact if you build it carefully
other actors can take a look at your
actors right and restore them whenever
they fail so you have a system that
heals of course we could decide the
certain failures are worth a complete
application crash a recoverable crash
but now it's a conscious decision that
we make it's not something that just
happens the second thing I want to talk
about is the synchronous nature and this
is fairly straightforward the
applications that we build or a
synchronous by default the user
interacts with it and we don't know when
that's going to happen so why do we need
to build up stacks of reactive libraries
to be able to act in that way where we
could be using a competition model
that's fit for it
and lastly truly parallelizable we
struggle to paralyze this single stack
based applications because we have a you
know a single stack running in a single
thread and any coordination between
threads has to be thought beforehand and
has to be done manually but when we're
thinking in terms of actors we
potentially run every actor parallely
that might be useless because some of
them might dependent messages from each
other but you can't do that
this is because you know each one of
these actors is essentially its own tiny
computer just think of the performance
game some applications would have by
just using workers because they are
available we are having to be rewritten
there is some three properties right
they they are incredible in practice
most notably in platforms like Erlang or
Pony when they they are normally used
for building massively concurrent
systems systems like whatsapp for
example were built on it I will grant
you that we probably don't want to
million users per browser but knowing
that your application can crash and
recover on the fly by itself it's
incredibly powerful when it comes to
raising the bar on quality of any
experience that we design and develop
the second point I wanted to make beyond
the computation model is the one of
philosophy and this is a briefer one
it's last point I'd like to make today
and is that most small talk applications
if not all of them are built on two key
ideas the idea of liveness of an
application and the Ilia idea of
directness of an application when we
talk about liveness we're talking of the
ability to always respond to a user's
actions this means that whatever you do
in the system and whatever the system is
doing they will never be a complete stop
a complete gap in the feedback loop this
is a little bit how the real world works
we're constantly sending messages
sometimes we get responses back
sometimes we get you know double tick
read but naturally as the workload of
the system increases you will expect
some performance degradation you would
expect the system to gracefully degrade
without actually stopping to work
entirely now do you remember the last
time you were in a website that just
didn't do something or anything really
for some time there was perhaps
something taking over the main loop and
your application just sort of stopped
working entirely
really we can do much better than that
and I think considering lightness in the
actual model how to work together this
failure as well an isolation is
foundational to recoverable errors the
second thing in the philosophy track is
directness or directness directness
means that everything you see can be
modified whatever the user is seeing on
screen that he can click her she can
click on whatever graphical
representation of the system we have is
the point at which the user can begin to
explore the entire system that might be
scary for some because you can
right-click on something and get access
to the actual source not some bundled
and minified version of it and modify it
but if they can inspect the button right
if we can change the attributes
restructure the behavior even
reconstruct a user flow to see their
needs better to suit their needs better
persist those changes and essentially
modify everything that they already see
we have an applications that showcases
directness really this is a deeper
philosophical question to ask to all of
you here is are we gonna be building
applications that model a flow that
everybody sort of understands and
doesn't actually empower anybody to do
better than they actually are doing are
we gonna be giving them bicycles for
their minds for their processes or are
we just gonna carry them around Hanny
hat so how do we get there I mean I
would venture that most of you haven't
heard of me before so it's likely hard
to agree with me right now that we need
to rethink the complete foundations on
which we build applications after all
with all this fancy framework so they're
backed by huge corporations how could
they be wrong right so I just invite you
to take a first step into this world by
trying out for our small talk just to
get a feeling of what we're missing in
web development nowadays what is it like
to build user interfaces user
applications user experiences in all the
platforms
Faro is a direct dialect of small talk
that is quite alive and has a growing
community in France it's mainly
developed an NRI I believe and it should
be more than enough to showcase why some
of these attributes are paramount to
increasing the quality of the software
that we build you'll find that the same
properties alongside a highly highly
reflective language allow for a
development experience quite unlike we
have seen in other mainstream languages
but seriously oops sorry but most
importantly why do you see that we can
do right now to start building web apps
like it's 1972 and my best answer to all
of you is to start by learning about
them Lucca line for videos people that
put screencasts on how to build these
applications with these technologies
there's tons of languages out there from
then and you were like small talk self
model a logo for us quick just you know
random names I feel like I'm reading a
lot of NPM packages right now and really
just try to get inspired by the mindset
take a look at how they're thinking what
is it that they want to give the users
are they trying to solve the problem are
they trying to give them a tool start by
asking why are we treating people
sundström this is kind of strong but as
cattle to put through a conversion
funnel instead of empowering them to
solve their problems by giving them
flexible systems with powerful tools to
be as efficient as effective and
effective at their jobs as they can be
I'm sure that we all are aware they are
learning curves for these things but if
you must have proof capable of anything
is of growing and learning so there's no
good reason to stop doing what we're
doing to know something what we're doing
and reconsider it we can begin today
with just a fundamental philosophical
shift in the meantime at source we're
working as hard as we can on formalizing
and implementing a universal act or
virtual machine we're calling a stage VM
we think it's a pretty good pun that we
can use to bring this computation model
on some of the goodies that we see in
the oldest languages to the browser via
web assembly the idea is not just to
target the browser but to do it through
web assembly
it will be sometime if we have something
worth damning but if you're interested
don't stop following source underscore
technology on Twitter and with that I
want to say if you're interested in
nonprofits for software I work at one if
you're interesting the actor model or
want to learn more about small talk or
airline distributed systems or good
currency please come and say hi to me
after this talk we can chat thanks a
million for the opportunity and enjoy
the rest of Jays conf
[Applause]
[Music]